Hãy phủ ban hành nghị định số 1.5 năm 2020, quy định về phân định thầm quyền của chính quyền địa phương 2.
Phân quyền, phân cấp trong lĩnh vực đất đại. Hồ sơ sinh cấp sồ đỏ tiếp nhận trước ngày 1.5 năm 2020,
nhưng chưa dải quyết sẽ được sử lý theo thầm quyền của học mới tuy cấp hành chính.
Hồ sơ đăng ký đất đai, tài sản gắn liền với đất, cấp dế chính nhận quyền sử dụng đất.
Quình sở hiếu tài sản gắn liền với đất đã được tiếp nhận trước ngày 1.5 năm 2020, nhưng chưa được cơ quan có thầm quyền giải quyết thị thực hiện như sau.
Chương hợp thuộc thầm quyền của Iban nhân dân cấp tình theo quy định của Pháp lật trước ngày 1.5 năm 2020,
ngày 2.5 năm 2020, tuy tục quy định của Pháp lật đất đai trước ngày nghị định này có hiệu lực thị hành.
Chương hợp thuộc thầm quyền của Iban nhân dân cấp viện theo quy định của Pháp lật trước ngày 1.5 năm 2020,
ngày 2.5 năm 2020, tuy tịch iban nhân dân cấp sá dải quyết theo chính tự, tuy tục quy định tại nghị định này.
Chỉ phủ yêu cầu cơ quan dải quyết tuy tục hành chính về đất đai không được yêu cầu người sử dụng đất phải thực hiện chính lý hồ sơ.
Dễ tự liên quan đến đất đai sau khi sắp sẽ, tuy tức chính quyền định phương hai cấp mà thực hiện đồng thời khi người sử dụng đất thực hiện tuy tục hành chính hoặc trên cơ sở như cầu của người sử dụng đất.